il en termine presque avec le tronçon
loire est un nicky loh depuis aix
la chapelle en allemagne en passant par
la belgique des badges mbola hadj est à
la frontière belge et d'injures quai et
j'ai rejoint la véloroute rois
catholiques oui
c'est beau il ya des arbres partout
c'est très vert il ya aussi une piste
bien lisse sur laquelle on roule bien
c'est vraiment très beau c'est la
deuxième année de suite qu'on vient à
briare et on se plaît beaucoup ici
sur 1700 km là ce qu'en dit periko relie
trondheim en norvège à saint jacques de
compostelle en espagne dont le loiret
elle emprunte 70 km de piste le long du
canal du loing et du canal de briare un
chantier à 6 millions d'euros mais un an
après l'inauguration les retombées sont
là on a énormément de demandes vélo cet
été même depuis depuis quelque temps
beaucoup veulent faire du vélo le long
du canal de briare donc du coup
empreinte la sq en numérique en passant
par voilà à châtillon coligny rogny les
sept écluses qui sont des petits
villages très joli à voir le long la
scandinavie ça permet de valade faire du
tourisme en même temps de faire du vélo
et même en cette période de rentrée les
touristes viennent encore au
renseignement
on va essayer de remonter vers montargis
le long du canal de briare et puis on
verra un peu dans le coin ce qui est un
moyen de faire
enrichir l'offre touristique du
département tout en guidant les
cyclotouristes vers des sites
patrimoniaux et des lieux de visite le
pari semble gagnant